this episode brought to you by
expressvpn the best VPN there is take
back your online privacy today
[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to we all
remember the true story of balton I'm
sorry I could say true story in
Baltimore the same sentence but to be
fair it is about as authentic as the
true story of Bohemian Rhapsody
well moto was not a box office darling
in the least lasting only three weekends
and making back only a third of its
budget if you'd find a decent life on
television and VHS / DVD so it only
figure to make a sequel a cinematic
sequel oh this is the early 2000s and
you know what they do with hand-drawn
animated sequels in the early 2000s its
cherry to DVD and you know how good
those always are right right Wow I've
never seen a dog put himself down before
[Applause]
[Music]
Balto to wolf quest again hallelujah
true story it's the follow-up to Balto
made a mere seven years later released
once again by Universal as as usual with
straight to DVD releases the animation
isn't as good as the original but we're
Balto to lacks in its visual elements it
really lacks in its storytelling
elements which ok is kinda to be
expected of these DVD releases but does
it in any way hold a candle to its
imperfect yet still under taining
predecessor wow they made a third one so
who cares money
this is Balto two from the font I'm
already expecting to see four canines
chase after a flower that concept
surprisingly more interesting than it
sounds we see Balto literally on thin
ice as he follows a bird to a giant ice
wall the ice breaks though as he sees
other wolves in the distance what was
the score by Al Pacino from scent of a
woman
it turns out it's just a dream as Boris
played this time by Charles Fleischer
instead of Bob Hoskins I guess they have
shared a movie so that kind of makes
sense wakes up Balto played this time by
maurice lamarche instead of Kevin Bacon
yeah like he's known for doing
impressions at all it's just a dream I'm
telling a budget if you keep having same
dream again and again it means something
for instance I have dream Affleck duck
will kill me I still sleep with one eye
open every night apparently being a hero
dog isn't as rewarding as one would
think as they spend the night in a
shipwrecked boat yeah everything went to
after togo protease should be on
the weedy box they come across a totem
pole that apparently has the same
animals Balto saw in his dream they're
just wood carvings Boris humans used
them to tell stories I don't know
Oh what anime a direct-to-dvd movies
were back then I've only just met you
and you convinced me dog genocide is a
good idea
Jacque two point blow tells him that
Jena has just given birth she's played
this time by Jodi Benson instead of
Bridget Fonda
they're so beautiful just like you I
mean beautiful enough to be here when
they're born but understand I had an app
[Music]
you can tell an animator really like
drawing that the putts get older is
Balto continues to be apparently a real
deadbeat dad good morning did you forget
about watching the Pops today I don't
think you understand just how important
these naps are they prepare me for my
daily slumber also finds himself pumped
out knowing that soon they'll be up for
adoption they'll have to find new homes
tomorrow we can all go on a picnic
don't you remember tomorrow is the day
for our pups to find their new home well
I don't think I can let them go Jenna
not yet I have so much more of their
lives to sleep through yeah that Jay is
looking a little too much I get tea for
my comfort
actually what did we sell there Balto
and Jen are concerned though that one of
the pups named a Lou voiced by Lacey
Chabert looks more wolf than dog
decreasing her chances of getting
adopted to Sado Alou looks more like a
wolf than me no human is every kind of
water we'll just have to keep trying
right here on toontown Road seriously
what is up with that angle so she never
gets adopted well screw that she's
so cute you could say she's a vampire
shark and she still get adopted and she
grows older trying to make the case that
she's not so little anymore uncle Boris
since I'm not a baby anymore I don't
need a babysitter and you can tell that
to my father I heard my mother do this
dialogue I know how the routine goes she
comes across a hunter though and let's
just say gets the wrong idea no it's a
human he wouldn't hurt me
maybe he'll wanna talk to me hey what's
that a dog biscuit maker I'm so stupid
so saves her a salut doesn't understand
what just happened I don't understand
Papa why did you attack him what if he
wanted to adopt me
that was an adoption bullet that came
from its gun right I get really stupid
he tells her about her heritage and how
Wolf's blood flow through both their
veins
helooo runs away as a Balto being the
good parent chases after her not just
kidding he sleeps again I want you to
stop focusing on being half wolf and
start focusing on being half parent your
daughter was almost killed a jackass
wolf jackass once again he has a dream
only this time his mother's beast to him
saying he needs to understand the
animals of the totem oh and the movie
wants to remind you these two were a
thing what are you two doing my daughter
was almost killed meaning it's vital I
catch up to my 30 hours news we had to
play with a loop you mean you can't find
her no god I thought you know where she
is
dad she's got to be at her mother's
she's the parent that actually adults
maybe she can find her while i nap
[Music]
weirdly sad she must have run away run
away I thought I could keep her safe but
she's not safe now she's running wild
we've got to find her oh that's what a
father does you know here I thought the
answer was you dare say napping not
napping
Balto sees it as his fault which it
totally is so he decides to go after her
alone good idea sending two dogs would
give too great an advantage so just send
the lesser of the two parents I'm
starting to see why Lou is so dumb he
comes across the Raven in his dream who
leads into a thought voiced by the late
Mary Kay Bergman caught in a trap say
I'll help you find your daughter if
you'll help me out of this trap did you
know I'm looking for my daughter do we
have a deal or don't we
no I can't sexy there Fox's voices it
makes me you come
used now how can you help me find my
daughter and more importantly who puts a
trap on a log over Rapids she pushes him
over saying the current will take him to
where he needs to go he comes across
Boris and the Bears clearly where nobody
needs to go and he tells them to let
Jenna know that he's got a lose scent
and not to worry about him as you can
see he has everything under control
looking for my daughter tell me are you
afraid ahead of glowey I'd Hellspawn
raccoon badger demons very yes you must
listen to your fears let them lead you
back to the safety of your cozy little
home ok Ali was found dead in the eighth
Boris no he admits he's scared of never
seeing his daughter again and they
vanish apparently that was the password
Alou meanwhile tries to find a spot out
of the hot Sun a Keith please it'll be
dark and cool like what's in burton
movies used to be she goes inside and
finds a bunch of crystals and a singing
mouse as you do I am a rule this answer
tells us what we are but not who we are
how do I find out who I am I am shedding
light where darkness lies really like
drink too much coffee and are on social
media too much totally isn't working
[Applause]
[Music]
hello hello toad this is a bunch of
people you know calling huh guys we were
wondering is there any reason you
emailed us all calling us a foot ha I
call everyone a foot but that wasn't me
I don't even like feet I mean if they
took me on a date or something I mean
maybe I get to know him but no someone
has hacked my email called a bunch of
people I know of course how did this
happen nope that make me feel better
foolish Doug obviously you should have
gotten expressvpn tell me more like this
is an advertisement about a VPN you're
putting your personal information in
danger all it takes is one time and a
hacker could have enough information to
steal your data they can open bank
accounts in your name access your emails
even access your social media yes and
not the good kind of bad and that Bad's
no good expressvpn can help though it
encrypt your internet data is it dad or
David why you idiot you've just been
half reeking talking about my job I
don't get you anyway to encrypt your
internet data preventing others from
sniffing your information when you're
using a public Wi-Fi network that's good
yes the good kind of good no that's good
ah expressvpn has the fastest speeds
consistently faster than other VPN
providers
it has server locations in 94 countries
giving you plenty of options to choose
from at for every device including
Windows iOS Android Mac Linux router and
more and it's easy to use connect with
just one click don't shake your head
that's a good thing but good kind of
good thing it's internet without
restriction securely stream or download
content from anywhere anytime
no wonder if the market-leading VPN
rated the number one VPN service by
TechRadar flight it's less than seven
dollars a month with a 30-day money-back
guarantee I don't trust that dirty
stinking fighter come on I was just
email to people I wasn't the one sending
the email why don't you say why you
enjoy Express feed here oh well on my
other computer it's really nice to know
I can get work done without having to
worry about anyone hacking into it and
stealing my information it's just a good
way to feel comfortable and safe that
was good what you're talking about the
special deal we have rights nevermind
I'll tell you can take back your
internet privacy today and find out how
you can get three months free by
clicking on the link in the description
box expressvpn comm slash nostalgia
critic take back your internet privacy
today with express PPA Thank You foot
phone you've convinced me to get
expressvpn on
computer wonderful do you think we
should end on a joke no good Oh
expressvpn calm / nostalgic rape - take
back your internet privacy today and
find out how you can get three months
free
[Music]
[Applause]
so the mouse voice bite Peter McNichol
tells her how the world of the spirits
works when every creature in the world
is born a spirit stands beside them why
to watch them undress it makes everyone
uncomfortable
he's a surprisingly nice song about
following her own path though it is a
mere what 40 minutes in to suddenly make
this a musical it's like if want the
spider-man movies had a musical number
deep in the film you know that proves my
point more have faith and trust in
yourself the church the mouse disappears
into a picture on the wall no they got
it backwards it's vehicle that's
supposed to go on the painting not Yano
she exits the cave coming across an
unexpected visitor oh it's a bear maybe
he wants to adopt me too so saves her
from the Satanic grizzly seriously
there's a lot of those in these parts as
a loon who tries to look deep into his
eyes there is no way we've got to jump
we'll be killed
the devil has claimed me I must destroy
this vessel it turns out there was a
Ledge to catch them as Balto asks how
she knew I looked at his spots and I saw
it how much of that five leaf guarded
did you eat all of it he asked her to
come home but she doesn't want to
until her journey is completed not until
I find out who I am huh that's
ridiculous Alou you know who you are
you're a loser like a big loser he
agrees to come with her so she can find
herself I'm sure her mother would be
thrilled to have those extra hours of
crippling anxiety they come across other
walls who have it out for them
at least we know the Ravens on our side
come on we can tango Oh
Ravens got this doggy there's something
so demeaning about using the back of
your hand to push somebody off like
you're not even worth appalled you have
the luxury of smelling my lotion as I
push you off thank you government it is
Balto and Alou are so bad at fighting
them off that the water does a better
job as the gangs leader voice by mark
hamil tells them to chase him down if
those two lives they'll take what's left
of our food Oh was complaining about
last night for Christ's sake get her
life by talking about Balto - what's the
real leader of the walls voiced by the
late David Carradine tells them to clear
the way it is I who thank you for coming
at last you know we were coming because
I sent for you you see there's a check
extra features I guess our summer is
almost past and I have listened to the
trees and to the blades of grass
thinking about the same five leaf garden
as you or I here smells caribou will not
return this year we must follow them our
leader has lost his ability to lead
don't you say that
let him speak right thank you you're
very kind anyway he's not very kind and
doesn't deserve our thanks we take what
we need from other clay from others
right yes there is a right our right to
survive the thorn berry plan is the
aspiration of idiots and dreamers and if
we eat the food of other clans
what will they that is not our concern
it's not the balance of our world the
concern of all excluding the caribou we
can eat them until extinction no wait
wait some about our bodies
becoming the grass problem solved
the white wolf has come to me in dreams
visions she said we must be led by the
one who is wolf and does not know huh
spoiler it's not him it's actually Ralph
it's a big twist see here our wise
leader who visits with the greater nigh
you only
dreams has brought a mud to guide us
okay he must have recorded this right
after Batman because that sounded very
Joker ish see here our wise leader who
visits with the great an IU only in his
dreams has brought a mud to guide us but
Alou who tries to step in and motivate
the pack
I'd say miju is afraid to cross the
great water I am Not Afraid but crossing
the great water is impossible
would you get I'm not afraid of
impossible I'm not impossible I wish
cuphead and Zelda to at the cross over I
love it that much oh did I mention David
Carradine wolf is also magic which sang
that sentence out loud makes me realize
of course he is I will be a leader who
does not depend on foolish dreams o
animators who draw my eyes sunny-side up
my eyes were eggs half the wolves go
with um with pupils while the leader of
the wolves reveals himself how did you
do that I simply became one with the
tree okay just because your ring kungfu
doesn't mean you can always become one
with blank actually a de Ulua has a
vision of the caribou and says she wants
to help the pack find them she tries
telling the leader of the wolves but
seeing how we're almost at the end of
the movie I guess we better have song
number two
like this movie which we stolen for
ourselves
I knew 2/3 was about to father-daughter
relationship and then we showed up right
the out of nowhere but we fought
hard for this last 20 minutes we're
gonna cram what we can hey don't look
now but there's a giant you facing your
back right now
one big sneeze that were both dead what
happened to my part in this movie
happened to my parts in this movie
look the walls find the ice forms a
bridge that the caribou crossed last
winter like not spread apart just one
clear path heading straight there the
odds of that happening once seemed
pretty impossible but twice that's just
science if we're to cross we must go now
the ice path will only hold for a short
time
I know because things the leader gets
separated though as a Lou tries to save
him but mark hamill wolf isn't done with
him yet hey if I could swim to you so
fast how come you couldn't swim back to
the wolves you were separated from
answer me stop you
of that Donald Dutch snoring what was
that
[Applause]
neat you won't leave her be no wait if
you can swim here from the pack you were
separated from now
I can help you swim over Nava no you're
right you won't make it you can only
turn into trees and probably water which
can in any way help us out here Alou
says Balto should help him back while
she leads the pack across the ice are
you sure
tell mom I finally found my own also
tell her I feel fine
so Balto has flashbacks to all the
moments of her growing up
that's right both of them he was asleep
for the rest balls float away to
presumably hit the Titanic as Balto
discovers his mother was his spirit
guide the whole time I guess I give
credit that they try to answer what that
weird ass wall spirit was in the
original but she just disappears and the
movie ends Yeah right there was that why
you cut to Jetta and Boris so briefly a
moment ago just to be like back come on
they weren't just in the first 30
minutes and then vanish they had two
seconds at the end but it was a vital
two seconds they looked at nothing kind
of like what you did watching the film I
guess for a direct-to-dvd sequel it's
not really that bad the backgrounds are
still nice the animation is passable and
the plot well disjointed did take its
time and tried to give some atmospheric
moments for the low bar said it does
actually do an okay job but yeah it's
still clumsy and/or rushed in many areas
nothing's fully fleshed out and it just
comes across as exactly what it is a
direct-to-dvd c-can kids watch it sure
there's nothing offensive in it for them
and honestly there's nothing even that
offensive in it for adults either but
it's hard to say that's a glowing
recommendation nothing that bad but
nothing that good either this is a
sequel to a true story that might be
underwhelming but at least it's not
painful
Dundas times are good a guy remember so
you don't have to
[Applause]
hey Doug Walker here hope for the
Warriors is this week's charity shout
out hope for the Warriors provides
comprehensive support programs for
servicemembers veterans and military
families they're focused on transition
health and wellness peer engagement and
connections to community resources they
believe those touched by military
service can succeed at home by restoring
their sense of self family and hope
their core values understand the
challenges pride and joy of being a
military family they strive to meet the
changing needs of those who served and
the families who showed support right
alongside them because hope for the
warriors believes in family united by
the shared conviction of honor and
sacrifice if you look at their site you
can see all the good they accomplished
and all the brave men and women who have
given up so much so that we can live the
lives that we live if you want to show
your thanks click on the link and share
how much you appreciate all that they
have given us
[Music]
you